we do apply the laws of the united
states
we'll continue to applaud apply the laws
of the united states
and we will do so to maximum effect for
the benefit
of the american public as congress
intended
more than a billion dollars will be
spent by the state of texas
where we're going to escalate the war
against those coming across
our border because president biden and
his administration
are not getting the job done
you know we're our lead store from uh
bill mollusion
along the southern border with uh new
video coming out today really one of the
biggest days for apprehensions there are
700 by midday
believing that it's more than a thousand
that they've seen
just today and among those
you have two convicted child sex
offenders
18th street gang member it's an everyday
situation along the border meantime in
our latest polls
you see an uptick in the favorability of
building a u.s mexico
border wall now from december of 2019
and then on the job approval as we
mentioned at the top of the show
when it comes to foreign policy and
immigration border and security and
immigration these are the items
in president biden's job performance
where he is under water
upside down his overall approval rating
is above 50 percent but these
are the draws the achilles heels
let's bring in our panel bill mcgearn
columnist for the wall street journal
charles lane opinion writer for the
washington post and jonah goldberg
editor-in-chief of the dispatch
jonah you don't see a ton of coverage
about the border
other than us and a few other places but
not a lot
and it seems like it's it's just
increasing
yeah look it is definitely a persistent
problem that is not
going away simply because most of the
media and the body administration
isn't talking about it and at some point
you're going to hit a critical mass
where it's going to be unavoidable for
the body administration
to deal with the problem because if the
problem persists um
at some point it's it's going to become
too obvious to ignore
and i think one of the problems the body
administration has gotten itself in is
that it's
too eager to stick to the narratives
that
uh you know that they came into office
with rather than like bending policy
and their rhetoric to fit the reality on
the ground
you know chuck vice president harris
obviously has said that
the president put her in charge of
finding the roots
of causes of the problem at first it was
to deal with the border situation
specifically that was kind of redefined
uh for
for the media but she's visited a number
of states none of them happen to be
border states
well we'll see what happens i i guess i
don't agree with jonah in this sense
that you know typically in the summer
when the temperatures spike the flow of
migrants
slows down so just looking at it in a
narrow political
sense i assume the binding
administration figures if they can get
to july
without too much more blowback they'll
be fine but as for the root causes
the root causes are the same as they
have been for the last 30 odd years
which is that life in central america
is substantially poorer and more violent
than life in the united states
people want to leave central america and
try their luck for a better life in the
united states
and we should finally rationally
manage our laws to facilitate that with
the most humane and least costly and
most beneficial way for our country and
one way i've written about that i think
would be a very good idea
would be to extend the legal immigration
opportunities for guest
workers from central america not just
mexico
so that they can come here to do
seasonal labor which is what many of
them end up doing and then return to
their homes
and then all the other enforcement we do
would be on a stronger more legitimate
footing
bill yeah i mean look i agree there are
a lot of different policy solutions but
you can't have a policy solution
when you have an administration that
denies there's a problem
look as far as i can see the biden
approach is see no evil hear no evil
and dump it on kamala who has wisely
steered clear of going to the border why
would you go
when they're not doing anything to fix
the problem so
what i can see is the limited effort is
to try to build
spaces to accommodate people which is
which is a zero-sum game they just can't
do it fast enough
i think they should they need to admit
they made some mistakes i mean we had
these agreements
with central american countries and
and i also i agree with charles in this
sense the real solution for all of this
is congress and to come to some kind of
deal
and that means give and take on both
sides
to have it because what we have now is
not a rational system
it's not designed to facilitate an
orderly process it invites cavs and it's
just one aspect of a lot of our
immigration system that's corrupted i'll
say one last thing about guest workers
i actually agree with charles but i
think it'd be better
to open more opportunities for guest
workers but that's anathema to a lot of
people
because they're not really voters a lot
of people would want to come here
work feed their families and go home and
i don't see why don't why we don't make
more opportunities for that
i mean this sounds good jonah all of it
sounds good but it also sounds
comprehensive and when you put that word
in front of anything on capitol hill it
doesn't seem like it's going anywhere
yeah no i i think bill is exactly right
you know when people ask me what my
preferred
immigration policy is my standard
response is
to have one um but instead what we have
is a bipartisan
bipartisan consensus to tolerate
incoherence and chaos
which fuels further cynicism and
distrust on both sides
democrats have have an agenda about
immigration that has a lot to do with
padding
voter rolls republicans are a hot mess
on a whole sorts of different ways about
all of this
i'm with i'm with these guys i think
guesswork guest worker programs do not
scare me i think rationalizing labor
markets as labor markets makes a lot of
sense
but no one has the incentive structure
in congress to address any of this
whether you call it comprehensively or
something else in a sane and rational
matter
no we always seem to be one election
away from
solving this big issue panel stand by
thanks up next